hello everyone i'm rich stocks in 1997 i
heard a cassette tape by veterinarian
and naturopathic physician dr joe
wallach the title of that message was
dead doctors don't lie dead doctors
don't lie now has sold hundreds of
millions of copies worldwide and has
become the most popular health lecture
in history so not only did i begin
following dr wallach's nutritional and
wellness guidelines i also began sharing
his message with everyone i knew and now
25 years later i'm still sharing his
message and i'm excited to share it with
you today on
this video
the full dead doctors don't lie audio is
available on our web website at
mineraldoctor.com
mineraldoctor.com it's free of charge
there are several other videos there as
well we have two other websites that
might be of interest to you i am a bible
teacher
and i have a website for the bible
teaching that is rich
stocks.org rich stocks.org
and then i have a website i'm really
excited about to help people reduce
maintain and control their weight and
that is simple3slim.com
on the
mineraldoctor.com website there are two
things on the home page that i'm going
to encourage you to do number one when
you visit right there on the home page
take the free
health evaluation that will tell you a
lot about yourself and then schedule
your free phone consultation it's not
some high-powered sales pitch it's just
simply to help you
determine what you might be lacking
nutritionally so today's video i want to
talk to you about dr wallock's
nutritional deficiency chart and the
four
health categories so dr wallach again
author of dead doctors don't lie he is
famous as a veterinarian for connecting
over 900 diseases
with nutritional
deficiencies
and our first video in this series we
talked about the 90 essential nutrients
we'll not go through all of those again
today but you'll want to be sure and
watch that video about the summary of dr
wallach's dead doctors don't lie message
so during the past 50 years dr wallach
has discovered
that almost all health challenges fall
into four categories
well that simplifies things for you and
me so that's what we're going to talk
about here today because once you find
out
what category you might be lacking in
that will help you to make up those
nutritional deficiencies and this
diagram that i'm reading here on my
handwritten notes i printed out directly
from our website
mineraldoctor.com so again you have
access to exactly what i'm looking at
here when you go to
that website and the diagram
actually
sheds a lot more light on what i'm
saying to you verbally so here are the
four health categories
health category number one we call hard
tissue problems what does that mean well
that would be your bones your skeletal
system the connective tissue
and the deficiency that dr wallick has
associated with hard tissue problems is
a lack of the 90 essential nutrients by
the way every nutritional deficiency
that's where it starts it doesn't start
by running out and buying calcium alone
calcium is one
of 90 essential nutrients it works
together with the other 89. and that is
dr wallock's message and that's what
makes this message different from many
of the others there could be some great
products we have thousands of products
now and so you can get individual
products all kinds of products but
his message is
90 essential nutrients which he puts
together in health packs that we'll talk
about in a moment so
health category number one hard tissue
problems what causes that that is a lack
of the 90 essential nutrients and a
severe a severe deficiency
of calcium and magnesium
again don't just go buy calcium
magnesium you need the other 88
essential nutrients for that to work
well
what are some of the health conditions
associated with hard tissue problems
this is no revelation here arthritis
back pain bell's palsy bone spurs bone
fractures brittle nails
calcium deposits those sorts of things
i'll not go through the entire list but
there's an entire list there on the
website mineraldoctor.com
health category number two soft tissue
problems
what are soft tissues well
that is your skin
your eyes your brain your heart your
lung your kidneys think of the organs of
your body you have the heart tissue
that's your bones your skeletal system
then you have the soft tissue
what causes these
problems in this area well it starts
with the same thing a lack of the 90
essential nutrients but then a severe
deficiency
in essential fatty acids
and selenium
so you need the 90 essential nutrients
but a person who's suffering with soft
tissue problems needs
additional
much larger quantities of essential
fatty acids and much larger quantities
of
selenium
health category number three we call
blood sugar problems
blood sugar problems lack of that what
causes it a lack of the 90 essential
nutrients
and a severe
a severe deficiency of chromium and
vanadium now you hear a lot of talk
about chromium
a lot of products that have chromium you
can go buy that's one of the first
things usually when people hear
dr wallach's message
they'll run down the health food store
and get some chromium
and they'll get some selenium that's
what they heard
out of that hour lecture well
they missed the main point the 90
essential nutrients
chromium is just one nutrient it is
important it is essential but you hardly
ever hear about vanadium vanadium so
blood sugar problems
a lack of the 90 essential nutrients
caused by a lack of the 90 essential
nutrients but a severe deficiency in
chromium and
vanadium
what are some of the problems associated
with that
and by the way i didn't mention some of
the problems associated in category
number two soft tissue let me mention a
few of those because i forgot to do it
acne als alzheimer's asthma blood clots
brittle hair but now we're on category
number three blood sugar problems
what are some of the symptoms you might
have add adhd adrenal failure anxiety
bedwetting bipolar these sorts of things
and there are many more i'm giving you
just a very abbreviated list here
health category number four digestive
problems now guys a lot of times when
you take that health evaluation
that free health evaluation on our
website here's what you're going to find
you are going to have symptoms
in all four health categories i can just
tell you ahead of time
your score is very important how high
your score
is in each one of these categories
if you have a very high score
which would really be a low score i
don't remember exactly how we have it i
think we go from 0 to 10 10 being the
most severe so you're not
unlike in sports you're not wanting a
high score when you take this health
evaluation the lower your score
the better that's how we've set that up
but let's say you take our free health
evaluation and you have a very high
score
in all four categories
what does that mean well a lot of times
that means you have a digestive problem
so the reason that you have hard tissue
problems soft tissue problems blood
sugar problems is because
you may be taking a lot of nutrients
but it could be an absorption problem in
a later video we talk about the good
food bad food list there are foods that
hinder
absorption
and there are foods that help you absorb
more
of the nutrients that you're taking even
if you're taking supplements
so health category number four digestive
problems what causes this
lack of the 90 essential nutrients and
a severe
deficiency of enzymes
and flora
that's the friendly bacteria
probiotics prebiotics now they have post
biotics so what are some of the symptoms
for someone who's suffering with
digestive problems here are just a few
allergies athlete's foot belching
bloating gas burping those sorts of
things so what is dr wallock's answer
now again
we cannot say
legally that any nutritional product
can prevent or cure any disease we can
say it with animals dr wallach was very
successful
in preventing and curing
reversing diseases in animals as a
veterinarian
we're not allowed to say that with you
so all of our health packs are designed
to
simply support
and promote better health in each of
these four categories
so to my right you see some products
this is dr wallace these three products
here
is dr wallocks can make a pact that we
call dr wallach's healthy body start
pack
this is simply a different form of this
this is a liquid product this is powder
this is our calcium product you can get
either one but these three products you
can get all 90 essential nutrients
but then we have as i said we have
thousands of products so here's what we
do
if you have hard tissue problems dr
wallach has a pack let me get my
products together here he has a pack
called
the healthy bone and joint pack
what's it designed to do
well it is designed to support
and promote healthy bones and joints so
here's what we do we simply take that
healthy start pack
and we add another product that we call
glucogel and now
you have
the healthy bone and joint pack
that's how this works
very simple we show it in this diagram
when you look on our website we have
like
a picture of a flower like a sunflower
and in the center we have the words you
see on my shirt here 90 for life that's
dr wallock's message 90 essential
nutrients so when you go to our website
mineraldoctor.com you'll see in the
center of that flower 90 essential
nutrients that's our message but then on
the petals of the flower
you'll see different names for the
products we have
that we add
to support these four health categories
it's quite genius to be very honest dr
wallach came up with all of this it's
just amazing the success that he had
with animals he realized he could have
the same success with human beings so
you take the healthy start pack there's
your 90 essential nutrients you add this
product we call glucogel now you have a
healthy bone and joint pack to help
support
healthy bones and joints then
moving to category number two
we saw that is soft tissue problems so
what do we have for soft tissue problems
you start with the 90 essential
nutrients
then we have two products we add i
believe they're right over here we add
these two products
extra essential fatty acids
and extra of the mineral selenium now
this healthy body start pack has turned
into what we call the healthy brain and
heart pack
what's the purpose of that
it is to support give you extra
nutritional support for soft tissue
problems to support
and promote healthy
soft tissues okay then category number
three we saw you remember what it's
called
blood sugar problems
all health challenges
almost all anyway fall into these four
categories
there could be some things i suppose
that you know you get bit by a tick and
get lyme disease but even then the more
nutritional support your body has
the more likely you are to overcome
these outside invaders we'll call them
so the third health category we saw was
blood sugar problems we simply add a
product
called sweeties
you take the 90 essential nutrients
that's the healthy start pack
you add this product called sweeties and
now we have lo and behold the healthy
blood sugar pack
well guess what the healthy blood sugar
pack does supports
and promotes healthy blood sugar
say rich will it cure diabetes we're not
allowed to say that
we you can't use the cure word in this
country maybe not in any country i don't
know that we would anyway
but i can tell you this dr wallach one
of the greatest things he says one of
his greatest one-liners is
give your body what it needs
and it will do amazing things
what a statement i'm going to say that
again when you give your body what it
needs
it will do amazing things now this isn't
my bible teaching here today but listen
god designed our bodies
to be healthy
to heal themselves
it's called an immune system when you
get a cut the moment you cut yourself a
miracle starts happening
all the cells in your body start working
together
to heal that cut
now it's natural
it is the natural process but it's
it's quite miraculous when you think
about it we don't call it a miracle
because
we expect it to happen
god made it that way
so the more nutritional support you give
your body the healthier you're going to
be
does it make you bulletproof no
no we don't claim that it doesn't make
you bulletproof
but it will certainly help so when you
add the sweeties to the healthy body
start pack you get the healthy blood
sugar pack and then
health category number four
we saw
digestive problems digestive problems so
here's what we do
we add these two products
we add a product uh
digestive enzymes
because again
a lot of these hard tissue problems soft
tissue problems blood sugar problems
very well could be a result of poor
digestion
so the first thing we do you take the
healthy start pack
healthy body start pack you add
ultimate enzymes to help you digest your
food and then you add a product we have
called flora fx
more probiotics prebiotics post biotics
those sorts of things now you have
your healthy body start pack has turned
into the healthy digestion
pack
and that's how it works
so we've covered dr wallick's
nutritional deficiency chart the four
health categories and the health pack
that's associated with each one of those
four categories so we are out of time
for today be sure to visit our website
mineraldoctor.com
take the free health evaluation doesn't
obligate you to do anything and then
schedule your free phone consultation
someone will help you
pick out the pack that's best for you we
have a lot of other products that we can
add i don't have time to talk about all
of them here today we have a whole line
of herbs
herbs are not nutrition they are plant
medicines and so that's why i don't have
them here today but we have a whole line
of herbs that you can add to these packs
to give you extra support but we're out
of time we are looking forward go to the
website mineraldoctor.com we're looking
forward to hearing from you
very soon